لحظه حرجه هي حرجه للامن عبر الاطلسي
النيت نفسه هو من يقولها عن توقيت التئام
قمته هذه في ليتوانيا
من هنا يطلق الحلف اصلاحا يعزز خطط الدفاع
والردع وسياسه الانفاق الدفاعي
ويطلق معه رساله وحده صف الى روسيا
ورساله دعم عسكري قوي الى اوكرانيا
سريعا تقدمت برلين وباريس المتعهدين بدعم
اضافي لكيف كييف التي ستعرض عليها قمه
فيلينيوس ايضا اجراءات الامنيه المؤقته
وصفت بالملموسه لكن ماذا عن مساله دخول
النيتو لن يخلو الامر من شروط لكنها لا
تتعارض واجراءات يعتزم الحلف اتخاذها ويرى
انها ستقرب اوكرانيا اليه
سنتخذ اليوم قرارات كبيره من اجل تعزيز
التحالف سنعزز دعمنا العسكريه والسياسي
لاوكرانيا حيث نقربها من النيتو وسنتخذ
خطوات شجاعه لتعزيز قدرات الدفاع بما في
ذلك خطط جديده للدفاع عن منطقه اليورو
اطلس كما سنتفق على تعهدات طموحه من اجل
الاستثمار في الدفاع
واشنطن هي بين عواصم غربيه وازنه في
النيتو تصارح كييف بان مساله انضمامها
للحلف خلال الحرب غير مطروحه الموقع الان
رئيس بايدن ادويه في حلف الناتو في حال
الحرب
لا يستركز على دعم اوكرانيا في حال الحرب
من العدوان الروسي وسنستمر في ذلك
حلفاء اوكرانيا الغربيون يتفهمون على
الارجح استياء الرئيس الاوكراني من موقف
يصفه بالعبثي والمتردد
لن يتردد النيتو كثيرا كما يبدو مع مرشح
اخر للانضمام الى صفوفه على خطى فنلندا
امكن ذلك بعد دعم تركيا التحاق السويد
بالحلف وارسال المجر اشارات في ذلك
الاتجاه يتناوب الحلفاء على وصف اللحظه
بالتاريخيه وبانها معززه لامن الحلف
واوروبا في موسكو تختلف بالطبع زاويه
الرؤيه
يرى الكريملين ان دخول اوكرانيا المحتمل
الى حلف شمال الاطلسي سيشكل خطرا كبيرا
على الامن الاوروبي وان انضمام السويد الى
الحلف له تداعيات سلبيه على الامن الروسي
وسيتطلب ردا لا يكتفي الروس اذا وهم
يراقبون قمه النيتو من كثب بالتنبيه الى
مخاطر توسع الحلف نحو حدودهم وانما يلوحون
باجراءات مضاده قد تفتح المشهد اللاهبه في
اساسه على كل احتمال